&gt;&gt; But how does color blindness come from cones.
&gt;&gt; So, actually before we talk about color blindness, I think it makes sense to
talk a little bit about color.
&gt;&gt; I think that's a great idea, because what exactly is color.
&gt;&gt; So, remember how we talked about how sound is a wave. &gt;&gt; Yeah.
&gt;&gt; light's actually a wave too. &gt;&gt; Oh, really?
&gt;&gt; And so, what that means is that, well, remember the properties of waves. Do you
remember which property corresponded to pitch?
&gt;&gt; Yeah, that was frequency.
&gt;&gt; Exactly. And so, what would a, for example, high frequency wave look like?
&gt;&gt; It would look like this.
&gt;&gt; And what about a low frequency wave?
&gt;&gt; Excellent. That's perfect. So, high frequency, lots of fast oscillations; low
frequency, fewer waves per second, slower oscillations.
&gt;&gt; So, what does frequency have to do with light waves?
&gt;&gt; Well, Lauren, with light, we actually usually talk about wavelength, which is
the distance between let's say, here and here.
&gt;&gt; And light waves can have all sorts of wavelengths, but we can only see certain
wavelengths.
&gt;&gt; Which wavelengths can we see?
&gt;&gt; The smallest we can see is 400 nanometers, and the largest is about 750.
&gt;&gt; But, what's a nanometer?
&gt;&gt; right, well, 1 nanometer is actually equal to 1 billionth of a meter.
&gt;&gt; Well, what's the difference between the big ones and the small ones?
&gt;&gt; Well, that's how we see color. Let me show you something.